[Musique]
des ukrainiens se réjouissent de
l'explosion de tank russe a battu par
leur armée mais la population ne se
contente pas de regarder la guerre à la
télé
[Musique]
des civils désarmés sont descendus dans
les rues pour bloquer le chemin aux
chars d'assaut russes qui ont fini par
faire demi tour il force de vladimir
poutine ont clairement été ralentie par
une riposte qu'il avait sous-estimé les
résidents les populations qui veulent se
battre pour leurs proches maison pour ma
famille enfants sont toujours beaucoup
plus déterminés à gagner
les soldats russes sont beaucoup moins
motivés surtout qu'ils ne savaient même
pas dans quelle mission il s'engage et
moral des troupes procès extrêmement bas
pour longtemps là il faut se rappeler
que des soldats russes pensa qu'il
participe à un exercice militaire en
biélorussie où sur le territoire russe
ou en mer baltique vraiment il ne
pensait pas ils n'ont après la dernière
minute laquelle est envahie un autre
pays en dépend ils n'étaient pas nous
serons prêts à ça puisque le jeune homme
c'est l'autre convoi russe qui passait
ici a été totalement massacré montre ce
journaliste de cnn le combat dit elle
ont été féroces dans cette banlieue de
cairns
et rob ressemble mal ravitailler ici
dans le crime y croise charrues sont
panne d'essence
thaçi
même en pleine guerre l'humour peut
désamorcer les tensions
les ennemis rit ensemble une
démonstration éclatante de l'échec de la
propagande de poutine même chez les
russes selon ce spécialiste sa stratégie
de bergues l'art est un échec donc il
n'y a pas cette vision que les ruses
viennent libérer les ukrainiens donc ça
détruit le narratif qui avaient été
construits au crémant est aussi sa
montre
disons le l'incompétence stratégique et
tactique de l'armée russe dans les
premiers dans les premiers jours leur
stratégie initiale est un échec et ça
c'est extrêmement humiliant à mon sens
pour le plus d'un coûteux
la résistance créative déterminer des
ukrainiens a peut-être déjouer les plans
de l'homme fort du kremlin mais les
bombes continuent de se rapprocher de la
capitale il pourrait amener des femmes
beaucoup plus massive beaucoup plus
robuste beaucoup plus destructrice que
ce qu'ils ont fait jusqu'à présent viser
les populations civiles les résidences
bombardé beaucoup plus parce qu'ils
étaient sont très limités au niveau des
frappes aériennes jusqu'à présent et
envoyer de plus en plus blindés et
possiblement donc être capable de
vaincre cette résistance selon lui ce
revers momentanée risque de renforcer la
volonté de vladimir poutine
d'écraser le gouvernement de kiev ici
sophie langlois radio canada montréal